[Musique]
avec des camarades ardents et passionnés
un jour sur une estrade notre théâtre
aîné accessoir de fortune décor
improvisé tout fut prétexte à se
déguiser et par
bonheur moi je reçu de tous les rôles
celui qui me plaisait le plus on a dans
le on peut faire le diable jouer les
tour pend aux autres comédiens on habit
dans
le on fait M face en riant sous son
masque car on ne risque rien nous
partons en voyage à travers le pays de
village en village nous jouons la
comédie dans cette vie ente nous
ressentons souvent bien des moments de
découragement mais je retrouve ma bonne
humeur dès que j'avance dans le halot
des projecteurs
[Musique]
en on peut faire le diable jouer des
toursend aux autres comédiens
on dans
le on fait
en riant sous son masque car on ne
risque
rien un peu de rêve et beaucoup de
ferveur voilà notre compagnie
d'amateur à notre réfertoire sont
toujours les bienvenus les chédœuvres
notoir comme les pièces inconnues et
j'avoue que Molière RAC nous
maribau nous donne chaque soir des
plaisirs nouveaux
mais j'ai
toujours un petit regret pour le
personnage que mon cœur préfère en
secret dans le
C on peut faire le diable jouer des TS P
aux autres comédiens on dans
les on
fait on r en son masque car on ne risque
rienour et de C me temps tout le monde
qui laisse
fr moi j'aime bien
[Musique]
le